so when can we expect you back
um about that so
but people need a king no they already
have one
that's funny it's time for me to be who
i am rather than
who i'm supposed to be
but you you're a leader that's who you
are
you know i'd make a lot of changes
around here i'm counting on it
your majesty what will you do
i'm not sure for the first time in a
thousand years i
i have no path i do have a ride though
move it or lose it hair bag
well here we are tree good to see
he you guardians of the galaxy back
together again
oh we're too fast hey
just so you know this is my ship still
i'm in charge
i know i know of course you are of
course
see you say of course but then you touch
the map it makes you think that maybe
you didn't realize i was in charge
quail you that that's your own
insecurities in there okay i'm merely
trying to be of service in the system
quill that's what i said you should
fight one another for the honor of
leadership
sounds fair well
it's not necessary okay i got some
blasters unless you guys want to use
knives oh yes please use knives
no no i'm groot
[Laughter]
not necessary there shall be no knifing
one another everybody knows
who's in charge
me right
yes you of
of course of course
hi everyone it's charlie i've got a lot
of requests to do a video for thor for
love and thunder so i'll explain what
the plot of that movie is they explained
a lot of it during the big marvel phase
four panel
so we'll break it all down we're doing
that avengers endgame blu-ray giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best
thor 4 theory on the video i just broke
this down top 10 style so starting with
number 10
thor 4 is now going to take place before
guardians of the galaxy vol 3. thor 4 is
tail
end marvel phase 4 timeline per this
schedule and guardians is now confirmed
marvel phase 5 just because james gunn
is going to be busy doing suicide squad
before he does guardians of the galaxy
vol
3. so very brief guardians cameo at the
beginning of thor 4 just for the sake of
continuity because
thor is off on their ship as guardians
of the galaxy again purge that scene at
the end of end game
but now thor may or may not cameo in
guardians
3. the movie is going to pick up a
little while after the events of doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
for
important multiverse reasons i'll
explain in a second but it's hitting
theaters november 2021
the last two thor films have been
november films so that's not a really
big surprise
they haven't confirmed whether or not
there'll be a loki cameo from the
alternate universe loki with the
tesseract from avengers end game
if he's going to cross over because the
movie is happening after they do the
loki tv series with
that character if it wasn't clear the
loki of the loki tv series that tom
hiddleston is playing
is the tesseract loki that we saw escape
in avengers endgame and create this
branch timeline so he's alternate
universe loki now who's still alive in
present day
they didn't say who the main villain is
going to be but don't be surprised if
they also use a villain from the
multiverse
that's why the doctor strange movie is
going to be so important because even
though the multiverse already exists
there's a lot of casual audience members
that don't really know how it works
and that's what they're getting into
during the doctor strange multiverse
movie
multiverse is also important for the
mighty thor plot that they're doing from
the comics
so nine the plot of the movie is based
as you would probably assumed on jason
aaron's mighty thor run from the past
few years
during that story jane foster becomes an
alternate version of thor
when comic book mjolnir from the 616
comic book universe deems her worthy
the reason why the hammer deems her
worthy is really important too because
it has a lot to do with what the marvel
comics were doing with the main version
of thor
in the wake of original sin in secret
wars what they did is when he became
unworthy of the hammer he stopped
calling himself thor
and just called himself odin's son and
they use the thor name as more of a
title that you could pass around instead
of just a regular name like my name is
charlie you don't pass that around
unless i have a son
and then name him charlie once regular
thor couldn't lift the hammer anymore
the hammer in the comics is alive it has
a sentience so the hammer knows
that asgard in the nine realms always
needs a thor
to protect it to wield it so when our
main version of thor becomes unworthy
the hammer selects another thor to
replace him
in the replacement just winds up being
jane foster who's slowly dying of cancer
they did not say if they're gonna do the
cancer plot from the comics like if our
jane foster natalie portman is gonna
wind up having cancer at the beginning
of the movie
but number eight as you probably
suspected mcu thor
is still worthy of the hammer at the end
of avengers end game so that creates
some problems they'll have to change the
comics quite a bit
taika watiti is writing the script for
the movie and directing just like he did
the script for thor ragnarok and
directed
and that movie was a mashup of planet
hulk gore the god butcher
angela and comic book hella so the
actual plot of thor 4 will be a remix of
mighty thor with a bunch of other deep
cuts from the classic thor comics
7 valkyrie is still going to be king of
asgard during the movie and
going forward into marvel phase five
they revealed that she'll also select a
queen to join her on the throne
new asgard is still going to be on earth
in norway but because
all those asgardians were unsnapped or
blipped back by the hulk during endgame
now there are double what there were
before still a fraction of their former
population before hella and thanos then
killed a bunch of them the old-fashioned
way
but the actual job of being king of
asgard would just be a much bigger deal
with that many more subjects to handle
six as you probably assume natalie
portman is returning as jane foster as a
main character during the movie
even though she was briefly in avengers
end game this is actually kind of funny
her cameo the reality stone scene was
actually taken from a deleted scene in
thor ragnarok that they just added
rocket to natalie portman never set foot
on the set of avengers end game
and never really had anything to do with
it after thor the dark world came out
she did pretty much everything she could
to get people to forget that she was
ever in a thor movie
during avengers age of ultron they sort
of relegated her
off into the distance thor's like oh
she's off studying science and asgardian
technology somewhere
safe but in fact too thor the dark world
heralded as
one of the weakest mcu scripts by the
fandom the same people who wrote
avengers infinity war in avengers end
game wrote
thor the dark world marcus and mcfeely
they also wrote all the captain america
movies
so part of the reason why they used all
that thor the dark world stuff during
avengers end game was to one
kind of make fun of themselves for their
own bad script but two
to retcon a lot of those things with new
scenes like all the friga stuff
to make it seem like a much better movie
in retrospect just a really funny side
detail
but five in order for thor 4 to make
jane foster
become an alternate version of thor
taika watiti said during the movie she
will be referred to as
mighty thor when she's in thor form
she'll have to wield a version of
mjolnir she has to be deemed worthy by
a version of the hammer and that only
works when you have mjolnir
stormbreaker which regular thor still
has right now
doesn't have a worthiness enchantment on
it so anyone who's physically strong
enough can pick it up that's why thanos
is able to lift stormbreaker and use it
against thor during their big fight
but here's the thing at the end of
avengers end game captain america
casually takes mjolnir back to thor the
dark world
so they don't have a version of mjolnir
in present day because hella blew that
one up at the beginning of thor ragnarok
the whole plot of thor 4 rests on them
having a version of that hammer
so 4 early speculation best theory is is
that because the movie is happening at
the tail end of marvel phase 4
after the events of doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
that they'll use the multiverse to get
themselves another version of mjolnir
for jane foster to wield
remember multiverse is also important
for involving the alternate version of
loki with the tesseract because wouldn't
it be weird to have a thor film
with no loki cameo they did the exact
same thing with thor's hammer after
secret wars
you have hundreds of different versions
of thor and secret wars running around
when they fixed everything ultimate
thor's hammer which
coincidentally looks just like mcu
stormbreaker
winds up in the 616 universe waiting
till another person came along to pick
it up
and become another alternate version of
thor that version of thor that wielded
ultimate thor's hammer was called the
war thor
he was different from the jane foster
mighty thor but it's the multiverse
hammer
explainer that matters three that way
you can have
two versions of thor in the same movie
one are regular thor
with stormbreaker and a mighty thor jane
foster
without having to make normal thor
unworthy again
and without having to kill him at the
beginning of the movie
your next big question i know is if
thor's alive and he still has
stormbreaker then why do they need
another version of thor what's the whole
point of this
well the reason is probably because
asgard must always have a thor
and at the beginning of avengers end
game our main version of thor
says he's sending off to intergalactic
adventures across the universe so he
won't be around to help them out
but you say charlie stormbreaker can
open bifrost bridges teleporting thor
instantly across the universe anywhere
he wants to go
why is availability a problem if thor
can go anywhere in an instant
so number two next early speculation
early theory
is that he'll wind up giving
stormbreaker to beta ray bill
after they introduced the character
because beta ray bill's hammer in the
comics is called
stormbreaker beta ray bill the character
was supposed to debut during thor
ragnarok
they shot footage with him for the
contest of champions the big arena
fights
then decided at the last minute to cut
him from the film and just save him for
a proper story in a future thor film
when he could be a bigger character
thor 4 is the perfect opportunity to
introduce him and before they confirmed
when the movie was actually supposed to
happen i'd assume
naturally that they'd introduce him
during guardians of the galaxy vol 3
because he's such a weird character he's
also perfect for the guardians of the
galaxy movies
he even joined a version of the
guardians team recently in the comics
so that's how you take away main thor's
instant transmission ability
but number one probably biggest question
you have i know is is what's going to
happen
to main thor in jane foster mighty thor
after
thor four most likely scenario is that
depending on what kind of contract
natalie portman signs
she'll continue to cameo as jane foster
thor every once in a while in future mcu
movies in the background
like a couple scenes here and there in
the next avengers movie but not really
is a huge main character like chris
hemsworth's thor has been
main thor will either probably wind up
sacrificing himself like he did in the
comics during war of the realms as a way
to sort of
ice him for a little while till the next
avengers movie or
continue off exploring the universe into
marvel phase five like look at what i
found in this corner of the universe
there's a big creature calling itself
galactus so post
all your thor 4 theories in the comments
below
there's a d23 marvel panel happening in
a couple weeks we'll probably get some
more details about what's going on
during marvel phase four and marvel
phase five
so i will do videos for all that stuff
whatever they wind up dropping
but i'm also working on more avengers
end game deleted scenes in marvel phase
four videos like fantastic four
in more x-men stuff so leave all your
video requests
in the comments below but i'll name a
giveaway winner when i post that next
marvel video
click here for my shang chi teaser video
in iron man easter eggs and click here
for that brand new deadpool 3
marvel phase 5 teaser thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
maximum effort
[Music]